bobby and i were in kauai we went to
this ranch and we i had
never ridden a horse in my life i don't
know if you guys know this i thought you
would have in the philippines
you guys i think i'm meant to ride
horses though i feel like my next
a stallion i connected with the animal
we got along and but before we did we
before when we first got to the ranch
bobby was bragging the whole time okay
okay all right are you gonna all right
can i just say this though easy because
i have arguments with
every point that you're going to make
yeah please have the platform go ahead
please have that platform join you may
have the platform go ahead
so we get to their ranch and they match
you with a horse according to your
height and weight and your personality
basically how do they measure that
i don't know well it's [ __ ] [ __ ]
the way they measure it's a gut feeling
i guess it's a vortex okay
so we there were like 12 people in a
group and then everybody gets matched up
with a horse i get matched up with a
really sweet horse named dudley
very calm mellow bobby gets matched up
with a horse named sizzler
he's really like the restaurant
no it's his behavior and they're like oh
sizzler is a character yeah
i was like and the lady was like i think
you guys will go
wow and so i get on sizzler and so he's
he's he's laughing at me because he
thinks that i'm
nervous to be riding a horse for the
first time of course i
am because this is massive you know
beast between my legs
but we know as we're getting on our
horses
he's like yeah i like he tells the lady
he's like yeah i've done this like i've
ridden a lot i
went to kentucky like he basically
paints himself a [ __ ] cowboy yeah
yeah
like he's a [ __ ] wild wild west like
he barebacks horse like mustangs okay
but what i'm doing is a fact i have
written horses before i know but you
made it
you were laughing you're trying to
humiliate me in front of everyone i know
but i just said i've ridden horses
before
i'm not a liar well i've never ridden a
horse
before because if you said that then
they would give you extra you know
instructions sure i don't want the extra
instructions yeah
so we go across this like jurassic park
beautiful
beautiful round yeah imagine okay by the
way kawaii you can see
in my periphery
bobby unable to control sizzler
is stopping every two seconds to graze
and he's like stop it
stop it you know how like
he's you know you're supposed to hold
the reins like this he's holding it like
this like he's [ __ ]
i was like has this guy ever ridden or
[ __ ] hold reigns before yeah
and he's like stop it and he cannot
control his horse oh could i just say
this though
now can i defend not yet i'm not done
with the story
we finally get to the end of this spot
and i'm thinking
i'm not sure if he's ever ridden a horse
before yeah
and so to make matters worse he's
already kind of frazzled because sizzler
is like not behaving at all right
and it's making him look bad as he's
trying to dismount
the horse just decides [ __ ] it i'll
dismount him for him
oh and bobby just rolls off the [ __ ]
back of the horse
and it's this loud like sun to the
ground
i was crying i was crying because all
you see was his little portly body just
[ __ ] just
like on the ground oh my god it was so
funny
uh defense uh it's
you know um hey did you have sizzler
did you have a character horse i get on
sizzler
and guess what half his ear is missing
oh
really yeah you didn't know that half
his ear had been chewed off
right so i'm going there's something
wrong with this guy right yeah
and the reason why i was holding the
reins that way is because the other way
he was so strong i couldn't get him up
i had that and my hands were hurting i
had to do it that way and yes i have a
portly body and my legs are short
and all right and my my left foot got
stuck in the stirrup
and when i was coming up it wouldn't
release my leg my foot
from the story it was stuck so i ran i
rolled off the [ __ ] thing
it hurts and it's so ungrateful like we
i did it
how am i ungrateful i wanted to
experience life with you and go horsey
back riding
and do ziplining and you make fun of me
and you
humiliate me i the best like in my head
forever and blaze in my mind
is bobby's little um short legs like
clacking on the horse's body just to
kind of get him going it was like this
is like the cutest thing he said come on
sit come on
click click it was a great
trip that was great and then um
we went also one morning and we
basically took a boat ride around the
island
yeah and why's your laughing
it was just a bunch of kids vomiting we
went right after
a storm yeah and then i called that
morning i was like hey is there
is this trip going to push through
because they should it's storming out